because i guess you were a kid when they
came when our films came out
right so we sort of made them for you
and it was it was
that's right they were made for us
like when you when you step into this
world it's a big deal it's
like scary and then and then
those films were
critically not liked very much or they
were they weren't written very nicely
about you know by the critics but what
did what we didn't hear at the time was
people your age
that that your generation
we never meet those people now really
love our films you know yeah
yeah
it's taking us 15 years to hear it
it's really nice it's changed my outlook
and my relationship with star wars is
different because of that i think so
sweet and because we put our heart and
soul into them and they were difficult
to make because they were
you know they were all the second one
the third one there was so much green
screen and blue screen because george
was
was pushing into this new realm that he
had
designed that he he was responsible for
ilm and he wanted to he wanted to max
out that technology but that meant for
us that we were very much on blue
screens and green screens and it was it
was hard work
and to do that and be passionate about
it and then for the films not to be very
well received was
was really tough so
it's really lovely to have this new
relationship with them now
and i'm glad that uh and then and
watching them again i haven't seen them
since they came out you know what in
preparation for this show to watch them
again was really cool
i like them you know i like them are
absolutely it's really good it's a
really good movie it's it's
oh
[Laughter]
but i would like a dollar for every time
someone's told me i had the high ground
uh it's so refreshing to hear you and
mcgregor say this to give us a look
behind the scenes from producing these
prequels yeah it drives me nuts whenever
people criticize the acting of these
movies from any of the cast like you
know it's yes it is an actor's job to
act to make uh unbelievable
circumstances believable right whether
it's on a stage or on a green green
screen set but that was like not really
done a whole lot uh
up until that point now every movie has
like green screens in the background
actors they're kind of used to it but i
think
all things considered
that cast did a pretty great job i agree
some of the dialogue was a little goofy
in terms of the way it was star wars
though like there's goofy dialogue in
every star wars movie i dare i challenge
you to find one even rogue one which i
love that has that weird scene with
vader and mendelssohn where he like
mendelssohn starts like begging or
something like that and his he has a
couple weird lines in that scene i wish
i could remember that yeah
but i don't know what it is about
the internet age where suddenly so many
people are experts on writing dialogue
in screenplays
like i i want to ask every single one of
these people who criticize like the
writing of um of doctor strange to the
multiverse of madness the writing of
james cameron movies whenever they watch
avatar and they make fun of guitar it's
like okay point to me an example of good
dialogue i just want to know what you
think
or show me an example of you doing good
dialogue like well for sure you can say
that for anybody i would say but yeah my
number one cranky friend rev like people
who are just unpleasable with with uh
like tentpole movies they're they it
always is oh the script was brutal and
you're like
okay i don't know how movies are made
exactly yeah
they don't know how movies are made i
was in a conversation yesterday where
this is the case and it's like okay i'm
talking to someone who has never worked
on the set of a film doesn't understand
how major motion pictures are created
right they're storyboarded out how much
the director has to say on it how much
the producer has to say on how much the
studio has to say on it so it's a drag
it always feels like the screenwriter
gets dragged it's because people don't
know how movies are made so they'll say
oh the writing's bad the writing was
just so bad it's like
you do not understand what good writing
is and people will like say like oh the
dialogue was just so campy it's like
hollywood film as a genre has campy
unnaturalistic dialogue because it's
meant to be plot forward dialogue where
you're trying to condense so much about
revealing a character in one sentence
that it has to be a little cliche
and goofy but that's the fun of it like
you're it's you're not meant to be
embedded in a conversation like you're
watching a documentary right it's like
you're watching people who are
representing things yeah you know
exactly that being said the writing on
this wookie leaks is a little weak it's
pretty bad i mean who wrote this script
who just starts their monday mornings
with the rants you're following the most
wholesome sweetest
non-bitter uh speech here by ewan
mcgregor didn't throw any shade at
anyone he even said like oh you know
they just weren't well received and he
kind of said it with a smile and here we
are saying like you [ __ ] if you had
received but he wouldn't have been so
sad and maybe would have watched it once
in 2007
[Laughter]
welcome back to new rockstars everyone
obi-wan kenobi will end with one of
these heroes having the high ground but
could we be seen cameos from two of
kenobi's clone wars cohorts that haven't
yet been considered by us
perhaps commenda cody or cad bane will
our favorite gunslinger make us regret
having given up our armor
apologies if i'm uh having trouble
uh vocalizing anything my voice is a
little uh froggy because this past
weekend i did my uh first show with my
new improv team here at san francisco
bay area if you happen to come to that
show thank you so much that's so sweet
of you all to come support us like that
it was so much fun but between that show
and between the bar we went to
afterwards that was playing death metal
i
shouted the entire night yeah i lost my
voice a little bit by the way well
eric you're not alone because your
co-host and partner in crime has also
lost his voice uh after a weekend of
shouting so we are gonna sound like uh
i was at a five-year-old's birthday
party telling people to get away from
the pond
uh so
that's uh
that's why i have no voice but uh we'll
get through it i think we need tommy at
every party telling people to get away
from the ball even if there's no pond
he's just staring at the basketball hoop
get away from that pot it's his pond man
[Laughter]
um okay well folks we are less than two
weeks away from obi-wan kenobi's
premiere on disney plus and as we close
in on these final days and look ahead to
these first two episodes some new
evidence actually has us wondering if
that duro's bounty hunter cad bane may
cross paths with obi-wan kenobi on daiyu
and we haven't really talked about
commander cody but commander cody the
clone trooper that kenobi was closest
with if if tomorrow morrison is going to
come back and play any cameo on the show
wouldn't it make the most sense at least
for the character of obi-wan kenobi to
to have to come face to face again with
commander cody or at least commander
cody to consult with the inquisitors oh
yeah uh
you know why he failed to gun down
obi-wan kenobi and uh reported him as
dead when he was not in fact dead well
there's a lot we can talk about here uh
first we want to say our merch partners
over that epic hero shop have released a
whole multiverse of merch inspired by dr
strange the multiverse madness including
some new shirt designs and even some
gargantos stickers and there's still
time to grab the limited edition
shattered madness shirt number 15 in our
latest obsession series once it's gone
it's gone for good so be sure to grab
one today at newrockstarsmerch.com
yeah all right tommy what are we talking
in the world of stars well we teased it
we pleased it
and now it's time to appease it
could cad bane or commander cody appear
on obi-wan kenobi yes uh uh yes the
answer's always yes everybody can always
appear in everything that's right
totally possible um after luke showed up
in uh
in mandalorian season two that those
floodgates have been open yes
in this case the cad bane speculation
really comes from some recent photos
shared by total film showing obi-wan on
the new planet of daiyu and in the crowd
behind him is a silhouette with a
brimmed hat have you squint enough
it looks like it really could be cad
bing cat bane is of course alive at this
point in star wars history just to kind
of remind you of the timeline obi-wan
kenobi's taking place you know eight or
nine years uh after the bad batch which
was chronologically when we last would
have seen cad bane right when he fought
fenix shand to try to get omega back to
the kimi noids
and he was so mad that whole episode so
much fun just to watch those two bounty
hunters go
it really could have gone either way
because they're they're pretty evenly
matched i would say now many of us felt
that after his memorable introduction
the book of boba fett such amazing
prosthetics mass construction the voice
work for the character was awesome be
pretty surprising for luke's film to go
to all that effort just to only use the
character for those few episodes of the
book of boba fett yeah i mean many of us
feel the same way about black santa
another character who was also active
and alive at this point i need more
black ops in my life definitely i think
we need both of them yeah i want to see
how both of them intersect with obi-wan
kenobi to be honest with you um and of
course obi-wan has a long history with
uh with kat bain from the clone wars
episodes a bounty hunter that he used in
many different ways uh in various plots
when obi-wan actually infiltrated he
kind of face-morphed himself his eye his
identity to infiltrate a group of
bandits
you know it's just fun to have them talk
again yeah now uh especially now that we
hear that uh the inquisitors are
activating all bounty owners all
scoundrels across
come on right at least we gotta have
like a john wick you know everybody
getting their notifications montage and
on cad banes com it's like oh i know
that mug shot
all right let's do this good news
plug-in plug in the cheek tubes yeah
here honey honey where are my cheek
tubes honey where's my hat
cad i'm the best cheek tube you're ever
gonna get in my mind ked bain's wife has
a deeper voice than him she's like
you're cheating for sure where they
always are up your ass
she wears the rocket boots in that room
now one thing that's always like amused
me about the cheek tubes they are there
to bypass a a jedi from force choking
him to keep his trachea from being his
only supply of oxygen
could not
the force choke also include yes
the tubes
just get just just widen your grasp a
little bit not to get the tubes no push
it with the neck no you can only do this
just a little pinch you can only get a
pinch
the force only gives you a pinch
fair enough fair i will take it i have
taken far wilder rationale to fill my
plot hole absolutely passed so i don't
i'm okay with that but let's talk about
tamar morrison our buddy tim
possibly showing up on the season he
could play any of the clone troopers of
course we've talked about rex before but
obi-wan was closest to the clone trooper
commander cody the one of course fired
upon him on udapa
now
you gotta imagine the scenario here
they probably would not come face to
face again because if they do one of
them's gonna die right you know kenobi
would have to kill cody and that would
suck you'd have to watch that i don't
want to watch that at all that may
happen though i just don't see kenobi
having to go to that length that'd be
like a really weird character beat for
him yeah but
sadly i could imagine a scenario where
the inquisitors bring in commander cody
yeah now at this point you could say all
the clone troopers have been killed off
right that seemed to be uh palpatine not
palpatine tarkin's initiative yeah a bad
batch they wanted to be done with the
clone troopers uh kamino
boom boom boom but rex is a very rex
cody and rex obviously rex is still live
we know we see him in rebels but right
cody could be someone very important to
uh this whole investigation could be a
consultant yeah and uh you can imagine
the inquisitors dragging him before him
vader dragging him before it said
commander cody you were assigned
to uh to obi-wan kenobi you reported him
dead you're right he's alive
uh can you explain yourself right and
then poor cody
or cody poor cody gone i yeah i uh i
could see
him being killed by vader or or the
inquisitor is like
getting the sufficient answer they want
out of him and then being like thank you
like you know
right definitely like that could be
something that they really do to break
our hearts
about the inquisitors yeah from the
get-go i feel like they have to do a
couple of those maybe not necessarily
commander cody but they're gonna have to
do a couple of those scenes where you're
like watch the inquisitors kill a jedi
or something and it's like just to
establish their brutality yeah yeah i
mean the uh that whole speech that the
grand inquisitor gives that i'm obsessed
with the jedi
yeah um like that could be something
that he says
before executing commander cody and
granted you know it would suck to see
tyrone morrison play any character who
dies but he does play like hundreds of
thousands yeah i mean they do need to
kind of cut down his workload a bit so
[Laughter]
he's like please
character off per show yeah
i think it'd be more exciting to see uh
tomorrow morrison play commander cody
instead of rex because just because rex
has more the relationship with ahsoka
right i want to see rex show up in
ahsoka i agree um but in this case i
kind of want to see commander cody yeah
i think that'd be fun um between these
two cad bane and cody who do you think
is more likelier to cameo i mean i just
think
the men's specific mention of all the
bounty hunters being called in means cad
bane's showing up
i think they
they created the live-action version of
him or at least the you know
television version of him that's not a
cartoon
they put all that work into it it was a
huge success in terms of response
it would be a waste to not have him yeah
i think so too i think
he this is a guy who just needs to show
up in everything yep like we i want to
see him in uh in andor as well you know
yeah absolutely if he is technically
alive at this point in history just have
him walk around in the background you
don't need to have him do too much yeah
just have him like getting alert and
just be like all right and we don't need
to see him in action i just i just like
being reminded that he's alive and busy
yeah
just show him work show him brushing his
teeth just show him he's getting ready
for work pour a glass of o.j or just
really like
being an excellent husband to a yeah
like satisfying her
she's just as much as she deserves to be
absolutely it's just it's just like uh
one of those like rom-com things where
like
she just pulls the sheets down and
there's cad bane just buried in her
waist
[Laughter]
wookie leaks we don't have voices but we
have
high high libidos
that's what the cheek tubes are there
for my friend he doesn't need to come up
for air he needs he needs an extra
oxygen source because that mouth is
working
it's occupied
[Laughter]
oh boy we have to cut the commercial
here
in this case
our commercial or ad spot our sponsor
this episode
is just uh really more of this kind of
stuff yes which you can watch tommy
every a weekday on the break room you
gotta check this out if you haven't
already it's our daily new live stream
series
a shot from our actual break room at the
new rockstars hq every weekday we talk
about the latest nerd news they break
down um videos i have made and react to
me oh yeah uh and they interact with
everyone in the chat it's it's uh
awesome there's a whole mandatory fun
segment that's always a delight yeah um
so this is where you can see tommy but
you can also see people like uh zach
cuddleson and jess clemens
brandon barrick oh yeah plenty of other
people who yeah
and occasionally eric voss when he's in
town sometimes yeah sometimes whenever
i'm around we'll take it when we can get
them yes
uh so be sure to check out the break
room live right here uh on the new
rockstars youtube channel every weekday
at uh 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific so uh
and that's not too bad for you guys over
in in the uk i think that's like 11. 11
or 2300 however you do 2300 hours right
before i go down for my nappy nap
[Laughter]
they are gonna hate that
all right uh tommy there's an
interesting uh quote that came out of an
interview with
multiverse submana screenwriter michael
waldron who is working on a new star
wars screenplay he told variety quote
it's a lot of fun i'm enjoying having
the freedom on that to do something that
is not necessarily a sequel or anything
maybe has a little bit less of a it just
doesn't have a bunch of tv shows and
movies that you're surfacing on top of
it the way i did with uh dr strange so
it's nice it feels like a different
exercise so what do we think mike
waldron is working on what is this star
wars movie that is completely separate
from everything
i am of two minds
of what i would like to see from this i
either want him to be working on
something that is so far back in the
past
that there is like
maybe some books that are legacy or
legends canon not not a
main canon
uh or
i'd like to see him work on a film about
when they sent the beacon out to the
force sensitive children in um
uh
uh the last jedi
you know and the kid
moves the broom with his hand broom kid
broom kid and then whoever else you know
i made possibly
a uh almost maybe like a goonies like
adventure with those kids or something
yeah that could be fun yeah um yeah it i
think it really comes down to the
question of like
what makes a star war a star war right
right like
uh is it one of the war because we know
a lot of the wars that happen in star
wars history if you're going back now if
you're going forward
no one really knows what happens after
right you know
uh the rise of skywalker right if you're
going in the past like we know there
were there were jedi mandalorian wars we
know there were jedi sith wars oh i mean
he could make like a war movie
yeah if he's going to award movies one
thing or is the story of star wars the
the story of the force right and the way
it occupies certain individuals over
time
and if that's the case yeah then can we
look at other force sensitive kids we
can look into the sorcery the witchcraft
right of of the force to me i think with
what waldron's strengths are
that is kind of the story i want to see
from him yeah is the exploit because you
know it's again we've come back to uh
defending these screenwriters yeah
because they need with their high paid
salaries they need us
to defend them because who would who
watches who won't who who screen writes
the screenwriters
uh i think one of the cool things about
multiverse of madness is like
the way it explored witchcraft yeah in
the mcu and the way it talked about
things like dream walking and the sands
of nisanti with like this weird
danny elfman rock music i love the
guitar stingers every time they would
get like real witchy and be like real
she needs she needs the breathing tubes
i i think waldron could do a uh a new
take on the way the force
works as well for sure
as a kind of a sorcery or wizardry um
it's just kind of the older days of the
jedi to show the more high republic era
yes the highfalutin classy jedi back
before it got all trashed you know
before danny devito got in and mussed it
all up i assume danny devito is a jedi i
don't know maybe not
i think he is he's got it right i i mean
the guy he can join his skills
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i think that's what i want
from like there's there's some upcoming
star wars titles i'm excited for
obviously that intersect with everything
we're seeing but whenever we're starting
fresh like let's just like go way back
hundreds of years yeah or wait forward
hundreds of years
uh and and show us like a conflict or
like a either a war or just something
that delves into the mysticism of it
uh
maybe back before
you know because now we have terms like
midi-chlorians it'd be great if like we
go to the era of star wars before things
like midichlorians were even codified
within the universe before they knew it
as a science or any kind of scientific
term it was just something that was pure
magic right you know we will leave it
there for this episode of wikileaks all
right we want to thank you all so much
for joining us again check out tommy
later today on uh on
the break room can be an exciting
episode i'm sure you can follow me at
eavos follow tommy and tell me back to
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever your podcast thank
you for watching and goodbye
you